mundial football et politique argentine
france a mis sur antenne 2 l'ultime
espoir hidalgo confirme l'information de
pierre salviac
il y à bien une action entreprise pour
retrouver les français disparus renault
georges séguy d'abord l'action la
négociation après mais la cgt et la cfdt
n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre sur la
stratégie
le président giscard d'estaing demain en
course
il promet dès aujourd'hui des mesures
pour réduire l'insularité
mesdames messieurs bonsoir renault à la
une avec une situation qui évolue très
vite d'heure en heure
après l'évacuation ce matin de l' usine
de flins par la police et percussions
sans incident et qui a permis aux
ateliers de grande presse de re
fonctionner en partie avec l'aide des
cadres la maîtrise et bien les syndicats
de la régie se sont concertés cet
après-midi et leur rencontre s'est
soldée par un échec nous allons y
revenir
la cgt et la cfdt ont tout de même
appelé à deux heures de débrayage demain
matin à l' usine de clignancourt et
billancourt pardon et 4h à celle du mans
et il ya quelques minutes à m'entraide
plein les syndicats organisaient avec
l'appui des partis de gauche une
manifestation de protestation
pendant ce temps le ministre robert
boulin invité les différents partenaires
à la reprise des négociations
reprise à laquelle ne croit guère
georges séguy que nous entendrons dans
un instant le conflit s'étend d'ailleurs
dans les autres usines du groupe en
normandie
mais tout d'abord le point à cléon
deuxième foyer de contestation chez
renault cléon qui est toujours occupée
5h ce matin à cléon après leur cinquième
nuit tu veilles les grévistes présents
reconduisent l'occupation de l'usiné
peu après la radio leur apprend que les
ateliers de flins vient d'être évacués
par les crs
la nouvelle attire deux à trois mille
personnes à la réunion de sept niveaux
la régie il ya une action d'abord
surpris par la combativité des os qui
ont décidé d'occuper l'usiné
les syndicats ont repris le conflit en
main pour exiger la réouverture des
négociations interrompues vendredi par
la direction principale revendication
l'amélioration du travail des os les
tracts affirme il n'est pas soutenable
de rester os toute sa vie des salaires
plus élevés et surtout l'enrichissement
des tâches qui ne se concrétisent pas
assez vite selon les ouvriers de clients
ces demandes sont excessives selon la
direction réaliste pour les syndics
nous disons nous que à travers les
résultats de l'entreprise conclut dans
le bilan financier de l'année 77 et les
efforts de productivité réalisés par la
direction de la régie démontre qu'il est
possible de satisfaire les
revendications les 3000 francs minimum
par mois par exemple
c'est quelque chose de possible c'est
quelque chose de possible et nous disons
que c'est sur une année que nous fixons
ans il concerne à la cfdt
les augmentations que nous voulons voir
attribuer au personnel et d'une façon
différenciée de manière à relever d'une
façon plus importante
les salaires les plus bas et de réduire
la hiérarchie des salaires à la région
le tribunal de rouen a donné aux
grévistes jusqu'à demain matin 11h30
pour évacuer lusine ici on s'attend à
l'intervention de la police comme à
flins mais les syndicats sont bien
décidés à éviter l'affrontement
la violence ne peut remplacer la
négociation du style surtout à quelques
semaines des vacances d'été
michel rocard le député socialiste des
yvelines s'est rendu ce matin l usine de
flins pourparlers avec les grévistes
la cfdt son côté a proposé quatre heures
de grève par usiné par semaine dans le
groupe renault mais n'a pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord avec la cgt sur des
modalités d'action commune
nos propositions ont été déformés par la
cgt dit la cfdt
georges ce guide son côté a quelque peu
d'armes attisé le conflit en déclarant
ce que les travailleurs n'ont pas obtenu
par les élections
ils doivent le gagner par les luttes
pour le sigui estime par ailleurs que la
situation sociale va se dégrader
à commencer par le conflit renault en
lui-même chez renault est en cours
d'élargissement les jeunes les os
militants de la cgt s'affirment comme
les plus déterminés dans cette lutte
l'intervention des forces de police
aujourd'hui à flins notamment a provoqué
une vive émotion que traduit une
protestation de la commission exécutive
de la cgt qui appelle les travailleurs
de toutes les autres professions à
réagir contre ces mesures d'intimidation
et de répression policière
en fait les ambassadeurs de la fameuse
ouverture sociale destinée à plaire aux
formes et l'opinion publique se présente
aux yeux des travailleurs en lutte pour
leur revendication sous la forme de
policiers casqués et armés qui viennent
les chasser des entreprises qu'ils
occupent et où il assume la sécurité des
installations
c'est peut-être scandaleux mais c'est en
tout cas moins hypocrite que les
parlotes stérile de l'elysée de matignon
de grenelle du siège du cnpf ou des
chambres patronales qu'ils acceptent de
recevoir les représentants syndicaux que
pour leur annoncer qu'ils n'ont rien à
négocier
la cgt qui je vous le rappelle ne s'est
donc pas mis d'accord avec la cfdt quant
à des modalités d'actions
scheer orient alors ses propos de
georges séguy ont immédiatement trouvé
un écho vous pensez bien à l'assemblée
où on évoquer précisément un gros
dossier social le pacte national pour
l'emploi des jeunes proposés par le mini
du travail la participation robert
boulin jeu boulet n'a pas cherché à
enjoliver la situation pour lui le
fromage est une plaie durable en france
comme ailleurs et il faut tenir le
langage de la vérité
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que ces
problèmes de l'emploi s'opposer pour le
gouvernement d'une manière dure à don
pour le p et je crois qu'il vaut mieux
dire parce que je suis de ceux qui
pensent que le langage de la vérité le
meilleur que ses problèmes de l'emploi
peuvent s'aggraver risque de s'aggraver
d'ici la fin de l'année
il faut que l'assemblée considère que ce
pacte national de l'emploi des jeunes
n'est que d'éléments transitoire et
qu'il faudra vraisemblablement que lui
soient soumis un ensemble de mesures
structurelles sur le long terme pouvant
répondre durablement et valablement au
problème du chômage
voilà pour les propos assez pessimiste
de robert boulin alors voyons tout de
suite avec daniel brême comment ont été
reçus ces propos dans les travées des
regards ni de l'assemblée et puis dans
les couloirs et bien sous une forme ou
sous une autre tous les orateurs ont dit
à monsieur poulin en fait vous nous
proposer un cachet d'aspirine
alors bien sûr il fera baisser la fièvre
il permettra à quatre cent mille jeunes
à la sortie de l'école de trouver une
occupation
mais cela ce n'est pas suffisant nous
voulons un traitement en profondeur pour
guérir la maladie
et c'est ainsi que monsieur royer non
inscrits qu'il mâche jamais ses mots
tout comme monsieur briane udf beaucoup
plus feutrée on souhaitait une relance
rapide de l'activité dans certains
secteurs comme le bâtiment les travaux
publics ou l'électronique
quant à monsieur noir rpr
la surenchéri en demandant une toute
autre politique économique ajoutant je
cite que l'emploi pourrait devenir le
détonateur qui mettrait le feu aux
poudres sur le plan social aux visions
maintenant daniel et bien l'inquiétude
était à peine un demi ton au dessus dans
les critiques et c'est ainsi que
monsieur de l'eedd socialiste a estimé
que le gouvernement était incapable de
proposer des solutions sérieuses car ces
solutions selon lui devrait s'appuyer
sur une planification démocratique
quant à monsieur boulet communiste il va
proposer 6 amendement jugeant que le
texte qui est celui du gouvernement est
beaucoup trop favorable aux patrons un
dernier mot daniel le vote rapide
oh non certainement pas avant une heure
du matin d'accord nous nous retrouverons
donc il faut ajouter qui hier soir andré
bergeron ont été reçus pendant deux
heures par le premier ministre pour
parler justement emploi et pouvoir
d'achat et que françois ceyrac qui est
directement concernée par cette nouvelle
l'ébullition sociale sera samedi 17 juin
notre invité à 12h30 dans notre émission
samedi et demi françois ceyrac qui
d'ores et déjà déclaré aujourd'hui
certains ont repris le chemin de la
guerre en faisant allusion tout à la
fois au greffe chez renault et à la
condamnation la semaine dernière des
responsables de pme par un tribunal du
nord pour entrave à la liberté syndicale
deuxième dossier de l'actualité les
suites de la conférence de paris qui a
réuni toute la journée d'hier les hauts
fonctionnaires de 5 pays occidentaux
l'allemagne la belgique les etats-unis
la grande-bretagne et la france
les cinq ont fait un sérieux premier pas
vers une politique occidentale commune
vis-à-vis de l'afrique avec deux types
dead la première et militaires à la
seconde purement économique
dès à présent les etats-unis se déclare
disposée à fournir aux africains ce que
l'on appelle en termes militaires le
soutien logistique c'est à dire
l'acheminement des troupes et du
matériel
d'ailleurs dès aujourd'hui des avions
américains font la queue à lubumbashi
pour débarquer les soldats les jeeps de
l'armée marocaine chargé de prendre la
relève des paras français à partir de
demain en effet les 650 légionnaire
français vont commencer à revenir en
corse
qu'américaines ou service des africains
ses avions géants laisser 141 qui
débarque à lubumbashi les soldats
marocains prenant la relève de l'armée
française la force africaine
intervention relève pour le moment du
voeu pieux
les divergences entre pays africains
sont encore trop grande les occidentaux
sont donc décidés à prêter main forte
aux pays africains
lorsque ceux ci sont menacés il faut
bien voir ici en présence du général
mobutu le premier engagement officiel
des états unis en afrique
les etats unis qui peu à peu refont leur
entrée sur le continent noir pour
contrer la pénétration soviétique et
hubert le danger de ces grandes
manoeuvres
c'est de voir l'afrique se diviser en
deux surtout militairement
c'est la menace agitée hier par le
colonel kadhafi de constituer un front
du refus africain si les occidentaux s'y
est un pacte de défense avec certains
pays modérés en afrique deuxième type de
dead de l'occident à l'afrique un
occident visiblement inquiet de la
pénétration soviétique là bas une aide
économique elle est indispensable pour
restaurer des structures un peu trop
souvent pourris sur le continent noir
avec en plus dans le cas du zaïre le
traumatisme crèches et les européens par
les événements du shaba mais à kolwezi
malgré tout la vie économique reprend
pas dans les rues vides de kolwezi
on ne rencontre plus aujourd'hui un seul
blanc ils ne sont plus revenus et ne
reviendront sans doute pas de sitôt les
quartiers européens sont déserts les
villes lentes étaient pillés et seuls
quelques boy attendent devant les
grilles criblé de balles un hypothétique
retour de leurs occupants
dans le centre ville les magasins mise à
sac ont refermé leurs portes sur des
stocks vide
l'atmosphère est pesante et près de
trois semaines après la reprise de la
ville la vie ne reprend que lentement
seule la gécamines a repris ses
activités et remettent en route
l'extraction du minerai depuis
la cité arrêtez je ne veux pas envoyer
l'arrivée des poulets 28 les actifs
européens et maintenant le corian 100%
est ce que les cadres européens vont
revenir dans votre usine pas vous dire
toute façon on a démarré sans heurts
est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez
reprendre votre production normalement à
la cadence d'avant les événements de
kolwezi
vous souhaitez une apathie d'hier et
l'opus la remise en route de
l'extraction du cuivre dans les
carrières à ciel ouvert et bien sûr
l'élément le plus important de la
reprise de l'activité à kolwezi l'armée
zaïroise doit en principe assurer la
sécurité autour de ses carrières et
garder les points stratégiques de la
ville
en attendant l'arrivée des renforts
marocain les parrains français pour leur
part campent toujours sur leurs
positions en attendant l'ordre de
rejoindre de book machine une compagnie
renforcée de 150 hommes restent pour
l'instant sur place à kolwezi
qu'allez vous faire maintenant mon
colonel est ce que vous allez laisser
des troupes ici à kolwezi ou les retirer
pour les faire rentrer sur le boom bachy
est bien pour l'instant
cette compagnie solidement renforcèrent
moyens d'appui reste à kolwezi
sa mission est de continuer à assurer la
sécurité dans la ville
cela que les cinq occidentaux demandent
au président mobutu d'essayer de tout
faire pour mieux s'entendre avec ses
voisins y compris l'angola le président
mobutu qui précisément il ya quelques
heures recevait le présent cas honda le
chef de l'état zambien démission du
ministre allemand de l'intérieur ce
geste monsieur marc hofer illustre bien
les difficultés du cabinet de bonnes
cabinet de coalition
monsieur mario fehr a été doublement mis
en cause ces derniers tentent d'abord à
propos des bavures policières dans la
sphère schleyer ensuite à l'occasion
d'une affaire d'écoutés clandestines
argentine maintenant hier soir nous
étions les premiers à vous annoncer que
des démarches très sérieuses étaient en
cours pour avoir des nouvelles des
vingt-deux français enlevés ou disparus
là-bas et bien michel hidalgo nous là
tout à l'heure confirmées mais en
restant modérément optimiste un échec
dans ses démarches at il dit ce serait
une défaite beaucoup plus graves qu'une
défaite sportive
arrivé tout à l'heure à paris du maire
de jérusalem teddy kollek
c'est le maire de paris qui l'avait
invité jacques chirac et monsieur
collègues voient dans sa visite une
sorte de reconnaissance de jérusalem par
la communauté internationale une visite
qui suscite quelques remous dans les
pays arabes
l'ambassadeur d'algérie à paris s'est
inquiété auprès de jacques chirac de la
signification politique politique pardon
qu'il convenait de donner à cette
invitation est bien simple échange
courtois d'invitation entre maires de
grandes villes a répondu l'hôtel de
ville la politique maintenant conseil de
défense ce matin à l'elysée un conseil
consacrée à problème de la marine
nationale
on n'y a évoqué la révision de la loi de
programmation prévue pour l'année
prochaine
déjeuner à l'elysée toujours des membres
du groupe udf à l'assemblée
tour d'horizon général des problèmes de
l'heure a dit à la sortie le président
du groupe roger chinaud enfin toujours à
l'elysée la préparation du voyage du
chef de l'état en corse voyages qui doit
commencer demain et pour lequel valéry
giscard d'estaing a annoncé ce matin sur
radio monte carlo qu'il ferait connaître
des mesures importantes jeudi à ajaccio
le président entend par exemple répondre
aux préoccupations ce qui concerne la
desserte aérienne de l'île une desserte
difficile et surtout un peu cher voilà
pourquoi nous vous proposons ce soir
encore le deuxième volet de notre
reportage sur l'île ce soir donc avec
jean-louis le stand les aspects
politiques et économiques du dossier
créé dans le domaine de l'économie que
le particularisme de la corse fait le
plus sentir car le pouvoir central ces
dernières années a beaucoup donné à la
corse
mais aujourd'hui dans l'île on se
demande si c'est toujours à bon escient
un exemple ce que l'on appelle la
continuité territoriale l'état
considérant qu'il était nécessaire en
matière de transport de rapprocher
villes du continent a réduit les tarifs
aussi bien pour les marchandises que
pour les partager et prise en charge le
déficit de la société maritime un
déficit de plus de 20 milliards de
centimes par an
mais au lieu de favoriser les
exportations de la corse vers le
continent et donc de stimuler l'économie
locale
c'est le contraire qui s'est produit
alors aujourd'hui encore on juge plutôt
mal cette continuité territoriale
ils ont vite réalisé qu'elle constitue
un véritable leurre le tarif
préférentiel à partir de 5 tonnes
constitue une incitation à l'importation
massive de produits qui gênent
énormément nous asphyxie et qui risque
de provoquer à plus ou moins long terme
la disparition de régression de deux
cultures comme surtout dans le domaine
des fruits et légumes l'agriculture
corse a besoin c'est sûr d'être
diversifiée pour pouvoir exporter ses
produits mais aussi pour fournir des
emplois aux jeunes car le continent
attire toujours forte de travailler
faute d'établissement d'enseignement
lycée agricole école hôtelière le
continent attire toujours les jeunes qui
pourtant aspirent de plus en plus à
rester au pays
dès lors la population vieillit il y a
encore aujourd'hui 80 mille travailleurs
assujettis à la sécurité sociale pour
cent quarante mille retraités ou
pensionnés et sur le nombre d'actifs
on recense en ce moment plus de 4500
chômeur doit mécontentement qui ne
s'exprime pas seulement par le plastique
dans cette course profondément radical
dans l'esprit les élus des dernières
législatives appartiennent tous au rpr
un parti qui symbolise ici plus
qu'ailleurs l'ordre et la sécurité
c'est vrai les corses demande beaucoup
au pouvoir central mais ils n'en veulent
pas trop pour ne pas perdre leur
identité
un dilemme qui n'est pas facile à régler
et qui explique que la société corse
soit actuellement une société bloquée
elle est bloquée par le phénomène du
clan et tant que nous aurons encore chez
novell nous resterons dans une économie
bloquée ou le clan vaudra toujours être
majoritaire et prioritaire en ce qui
concerne la désignation d'emplois et
comment dirais-je qu'ils feraient leur à
toute expansion
dès lors qu'elles ne peuvent pas à sa
clientèle en corse aujourd'hui c'est le
silence
peu de personne même les officiels
acceptent de parler devant une caméra
pourtant la corse que valéry giscard
d'estaing a des coupures au cours de son
voyage officiel
eh bien le pays des traditions
car quelles que soient les efforts
entrepris pour intégrer davantage une
région à l'ensemble national à
l'ensemble france est une île reste une
île le tempérament de ses habitants
demeure le même avec ses qualités et il
faut bien le dire aussi parfois c'est
excellent voilà la traversée de
reportages nous avons essayé de vous
présenter une esquisse des problèmes
corse mais la corse bien entendu c'est
encore une identité plus riches que nous
ne pouvons exprimer en quelques minutes
savez vous ce qu'est l'héliciculture
bête tout simplement l'élevage
d'escargots
dit comme ça ça fait plus sérieux mais
il faut pas se moquer l'élevage est
délicat et beaucoup de ceux qui le
pratiquent n'arrive plus à
approvisionner les restaurants temps les
demandes sont importantes
et pourtant les trois quarts des
escargots consommés en france sont
importés importés des pays de l'est
c'est au détour d'un chemin de terre que
l'on découvre à ghoul 20 dans le
finistère-nord un élevage aussi
intéressant qu original ici sur une
toute petite superficie raymond fayolle
élèves avec passion bon nombre
d'escargots destiné aux restaurateurs du
coin
qu'est ce que vous faites la passion
pagnol et bien je suis en train de
ramasser mais hpm parce que nous allons
vider ce parc vaut quoi
mais hp m les habitations pour
mollusques ce sont des petits bâtiments
qu'on empile des petits des petits
casiers comme celui ci que l'on empile
des uns sur les autres et qui servent
d'abri aux escargots
c'est si vous voulez un petit peu la
réduction de la tour montparnasse à la
sorbonne à manger sur le dessus à la
surface restaurants 10 ans et ensuite
ils se réfugient dans une chambre à
coucher dont les prix seront pour
rentrer comme ici raymond fayolle a
intensifié son élevage
après les parquets ce cargo situé à
l'extérieur il se lance dans l'élevage
intensif sous serre climatisée avec tous
les gadgets qu'un éleveur d'escargots
heureux peut espérer posséder
jugez plutôt à quoi sert cette bande
métallique que l'on voit là cette bande
métallique c'est une clôture électrique
pour escargot pour empêcher les évasions
des escargots
il ya un faible courant qui passe entre
les différentes bandes et le contact
d'un escargot sur cette bande le fait se
rétracter la preuve d'ouvriers je fais
une petite démonstration si vous voulez
bien voilà il suffit de
et qu'est ce qui se passe là monsieur
fayolle au bail se passe pas grand chose
c'est un système d'alarmé système de
contrôle c'est à dire que si une limace
restent collées sur les bandes par
exemple se dessèchent parce qu'il est
plutôt à ce que ce cargo c'est le se
dessèchent
elle fait court circuit alors je vous
provoque cac avec mon couteau maintenant
artificiellement
oui ou si simplement couteau je mets sur
les bandes qui je fais sur ce parc du
bord c'est la même chose
voyez je provoque un court-circuit donc
ça s'allume donc on est toujours prévenu
s'il ya une anomalie dans le circuit à
la limite vous auriez pu mettre un
système d'alarmé sonore ou plus honnête
des pétards ou bien entendu raymond
fayolle collectionne les coquilles
d'escargot mais il publie aussi un
journal qui intéressent et concerne tous
les éleveurs d'escargots petite brochure
cela s'appelle la feuille de chou et
c'est le plus beau chien paraître de
trois mois où on donne les quantités de
renseignement pique nique qui intéresse
tous les difficultés lui même des gens
qui ne sont pas des sculpteurs mais qui
tue veulent s'y intéresser mais vous
conseilleriez volontiers à des gens de
faire de l'élevage d'escargots
moi je le conseillerai oui bien sûr je
le conseillerai plus que facile nous ça
ne prend pas beaucoup de temps et puis
même c'est comme le loto se fera pour
qui regroupe en tout cas ça n'empêche
pas raymond fayolle d'être familier avec
ses petites bébêtes moment prenez de ses
enfants
son nom
hbm habitations pour mollusques pénis
maintenant un roland garros avec tout
d'abord un joyeux anniversaire destiné à
bienne bord le champion suédois favori
numéro 1 des internationaux de france à
22 ans aujourd'hui c'est borg avait à
faire à cet art mis à rude partie il
affrontait sur le court central roscoe
tanner le gaucher avec bombardier roscoe
tanner l'homme qui avait plus puissant
service du monde certains de ses
premiers services ont été mesurés à une
vitesse approchant les 200 kg et son
arme principale ici à roland garros elle
en a usé et abusé à wimbledon sur
l'herbe ou les balles vont encore plus
vite qu'il en mettra certainement plus
d'un en difficulté mais ce soir sur le
court central il était handicapé par
l'humidité du sol qui ralentissait les
balles
il avait aussi en face de lui un garçon
qui s'appelle bjorn borg et qui est le
meilleur joueur de tennis du monde dont
le jeu au fond du court aussi bien que
dans ses montées au filet il est
inégalable aux quotas nerfs malgré son
service n'a rien pu faire il a sans
doute réussi de nombreuses s2 il a aussi
commis beaucoup on est un peu d'ampleur
alors à propos de borg
on se demande bien qui pourrait le
battre même avis là sans super forme ne
serait pas assurée de la victoire est
finalement borg bat anr 6 2 6 4 7 6
philippe chatrier le pré hier la
fédération française de tennis a
confirmé aujourd'hui la prochaine
transformation de roland garros
d'ici à deux ans un court central de
18000 places et l'aménagement d'un autre
cours de 4000 places de tout financé par
les bénéfices du savoir
et puis bien sûr il ya ce soir sur un
thème de la soirée football non-stop le
détail vous sera donné dans quelques
minutes par daniela ce cas mais sachez
que pour satisfaire les téléspectateurs
tunisiens qui sont nombreux à regarder
nos programmes nous ont choisi de
diffuser à 22h35 tunisie pologne plutôt
kalman mexique
le tout avant bien sûr le match grand
match et espérons france argentine à
minuit mais tout d'abord le point sur
une autre rencontre qui se termine et
qui intéresse les français au premier
chef italien
après six minutes je vous invite à lire
la vie et l'italie mène par 3 buts à 1
je pense que nous allons voir le premier
but puis c'est fait nous avons vu le
premier but à la suite d'un tir
d'antonio ni le numéro 9 c'est un
reprendre ralenti derrière au ralenti
oui j'ai regardé le mauvais écran parce
que j'ai en même temps direct et voyez
que ce tir prend le gardien mezin
recettes contre pied et c'est paolo
rossi qui suit et qui marque et une
minute plus tard c'est bettega sur une
longue balle de par delhi qui marque le
deuxième but alors que vous voyez que la
défense hongroise quand même n'est pas
exempte de reproches 2 à 0 donc à la mi
temps
un coup dur pour les italiens oui et les
hongrois parle exactement à la 60e
minute c'est benetti qui a marqué un
troisième but et puis après les finales
un penalty à la 80e minute pour les
hongrois en direct et voilà alors il
reste exactement quatre minutes à jouer
l'italie pratiquement h en billet en
poche pour le deuxième tour et ça ne
fait pas les affaires de la france qui
est dans l'obligation impérative de
battre l'argentine tout à l'heure à zéro
heure 15 sur la deuxième chaîne si elle
veut conserver une production
c'est bien nous serons au rendez vous
saluons pour terminer le dernier album
de goscinny qui nous a quittés il ya
quelques mois vous le voici donc
iznogoud
et puis la météo aujourd'hui le temps
était beau sur la moitié est du pays et
nuageux avec des orages surtout
l'après-midi sur la moitié ouest pour
demain il y attend très brumeux sur
l'ensemble du pays avec pluies et orages
en fin de journée vents faibles
températures en baisse
pas de dernier journal à cause du
football bien sûr je souhaite à tous une
excellente fin de soirée j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver donné au
revoir